hello how reject nation it's Greg Alba
here I got a message from not today door
and over at patreon one of our top
patrons telling me about how the DC TV
crisis on Earth X cross over a full
trailer has been released I am a little
bit behind on arrow and flash I'm only
on like Episode four of arrow and of the
latest season an episode three of flash
to the latest season I'm super behind on
DC's legends of tomorrow a lot a lot of
catch-up there's a lot of TV in the
world people if you want to catch up
with me stay up to date war I'm caught
up you can follow us on the Stardust app
at the real rejects there we do
30-second reactions for like film TV
shows any time I watch one of the
episodes from the DC TV shows I put up a
reaction for it doing that for the
Punisher right now - anyway let's get to
it
patron the day shout out even though
Natalie told me about this I made a
promise a promise mr. Frodo the Gareth
Hood that I would give his son use of a
shout out when it comes to flash I still
love you you're still very beautiful and
John will make out with you one day I
don't worry
I got the girl yeah you do
[Music]
I'm supposed to be all mental always
guilt on yourself
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
just when they thought they would
finally get married
I hate Nazis
oh snap oh damn what
are they all like alternate versions of
them that's cool hey captain ko
[Music]
it's really cool
[Music]
hero shots they doing it that way again
where it's each episodes crossover from
all four from each one of the shows that
looks crazy I think what I picked up
from that trailer is that this alternate
earth they're fighting alternate
versions of themselves which is just
bonkers that sounds really cool the
duper show I always like when they do
this like epic super serious trailers
because you know when you watch the show
that's always like really cheesy and
corny and super fast paced I really
think this is gonna be one hell of an
awesome time my favorite shot was just
heatwave sleeping at the church man and
Captain Cold is he back because I
remember what happens in season 1 of
legends of tomorrow I haven't started
season 2 someone needs to put a spoiler
comment down below I'm Captain Cold I
like the way he delivers his lines I
mean if you're not gonna get full on
dark Superman in Justice League my eyes
only a full-on dark Supergirl here them
taking on Nazis an alternate world where
the Nazis have ruled a we can all get on
board with that if you like Nazis you
shouldn't be watching this channel this
channel is all about anti Nazis I really
love the crossovers because every time
they do them they don't like super
advanced the story all that much they
might have a plot thing here or there
that does really carry on through the
rest of each one of the individual show
seasons overall they're just ultimate
fanservice
you just watch them to just watch them
kick ass and banter with each other with
all the movies that have all these
crossover things going on this shows
themselves feel the most like comic
books to me and that's why I get a huge
kick out of them they're cheesy they're
corny but man do I love watching the
hell out of them and then when they have
their heartfelt moments that can often
bring me to tears I'm excited to check
this out I got like a week to catch up
I'm probably only gonna do flash niro I
don't think I can binge all of DC's
legends of tomorrow in time I'll do my
best catch up with flash and arrow
and yeah that'd be fun to cover this
they'll be really fun to cover this mmm
and like I promised Gareth hood
Gareth hood has been our top patron
since the beginning of us having a
patreon this man is one hell of a
good-looking British gem with an awesome
Sun you so if we did a Google hangout
with him in use if they are so fun they
have the most awesome father-son dynamic
it's like watching a British comedy when
those two are talking with each other
Gareth hood I remembered you told me
that the next time I shadowed you out to
tell people about your awesome Instagram
take a look at these sexy pics from his
Instagram people look at this guy look
how sexy is the Alpha Hotel he likes his
cars he likes his bikes this guy really
knows his stuff
I think Gareth hood is secretly a
billionaire and he just won't tell us no
wonder you're a top pledge patron can
you increase your pledge of kidding
Gareth you are one hell of a sincere man
and you can follow this guy at the
Gareth hood Greg Alba follows him the
real rejects Instagram follow them so
you should too are you excited that
snart is back I'm back in the game here
to help fight the world I'm a cocky guy
with a hard exterior and I'm really
sensitive on the inside but does he talk
that way subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification now follow us on
social media and also make sure to
follow us on the Stardust at people
while I'm catching up with these shows
if you want to know we're on that you
can follow us there so I can give you my
quick opinions on each one of those
episodes that I finally catch up to ice